all right everybody I realize people are
still filtering in but we'll get the
kind of preamble started what everyone's
doing that because I have 72 slides and
code demos to get through so it's quite
a challenge in an hour so I don't want
to waste too much time well we kind of
wait around for everyone to appear so
hopefully you are here to see me talk
about clean architecture which is Bob
Martin's principle that there are been a
number of architectures and design
approaches over time that are
essentially the same thing and he's kind
of taken the best of those principles
and since analyzed it together my name
is Ian Cooper is my twitter handle there
on the bottom of the screen and my
github address the slides and the code
are all on github if you want to obtain
them you can even get them during the
presentation if you would like so Who am
I I'm just old most of that is
unimportant so we will move on quickly I
work on an open source project called
brighter brighter and a sister project
called darker I can essentially be used
to help you build CQRS systems and
you'll see a tiny bit of code from them
at the end so brides can be used in a
simple computer similar way to mediator
but they also support out of process
handlers similar to say mass transit and
then service bus so you may want to
check those out we got any stickers we
went for ages trying to get Scott Hanson
to tweet about us and write a blog post
about us so we get some visibility we
had we couldn't get anything and then we
got stickers printed and Scott was kind
of like oh I'm gonna talk about them now
they've got stickers so that's the key
if you have an open-source project get
stickers okay what's our agenda so I'm
gonna start by talking about this idea
of coupling and cohesion hopefully for
many of you that's a bit of a refresher
and then we'll talk there from that
about what layering is I know that the
cool kids are down on layering they're
wrong and I will explain to you why
they're wrong to be down on layering
we're talking a little bit about domain
models where kind of behavior and state
goes in relation particular to layering
and then we'll talk about this old idea
called the use case controller
specifically there's no thunder idea
we'll talk about when we talk people
talk about vertical slice architectures
they are really just repeating stuff
from 20 years ago called use case
controllers or boundary controller
entity and then we'll talk about the
clean architecture itself which has
really built on what everything we've
talked about earlier I'm going to show
you exactly what Uncle Bob was proposing
the synthesized version it's
architecture looks like and then we will
do a quick demo in dotnet of taking code
from maybe in a format you have it in
today where a lot of your behavior is
inside your web controller and pushing
it through to this architecture by
series of steps okay
so quite ambitious okay this is Robert
Martin and his book clean architecture
he's Robert - obviously those the the
don't name is mainly famous for what
could agile software engineering where
he introduced the solid principles and a
series of principles basically around
components as well which don't get as
referenced which are relevant to this
talk but this book clean architecture
identified that a number of people so
each picked will pick out three of them
I've come with the same architecture so
Alastair Coburn created this idea called
ports and adapters who's heard of the
port's adapters architecture anyone okay
Jeffery Palomo independently came with
an idea called the onion architecture it
said the onion architecture okay more of
you so yeah the time that happened a lot
of us are saying hey Jeffrey don't you
know about forsen adapters but this the
evidence does seem to be it's been
crated independently in number times and
either Jakob sin never done it know who
your IV yak of sin is the youngsters
amongst you know who IV åkesson is and
no IV a kiss is one of the godfathers of
object orientation and he's the guy
behind particularly use cases the
rational unified process and he got an
idea called boundaries controllers and
entities okay so what can I start at the
beginning and work our way up to where
Bob is so one of my current job titles
includes the word architect and while we
can be down on that title or not one of
the key things that's an active
see of architecture is partitioning your
system in other words slicing your
system up into pieces to make it usually
more maintainable right software spends
most of its cost in maintenance so
really when we talk about improving the
example of productivity development
teams it's a force goal to say that our
real objective for approving
productivity is to seam C teams deliver
to market quicker for this given one
project what we want to see is to have
software that's easily maintainable so
they can continue to deliver to market
in a productive fashion what we can get
if we don't address this issue is that
you you know you put your start up you
release quickly you get out into market
you start building your software and
then at some point you realize the cost
of shipping any new feature change is
huge people in the business start saying
to you why is it so expensive to get
software out the door and the answer
usually is that you have high coupling
and poor cohesion so we want to
basically reduce the coupling and
improve the cohesion to improve the
modify ability of the system and what we
can really identify the clean
architecture as as what as a system
that's prioritizing maintenance and it's
prioritizing having low coupling and
high cohesion in the system so it's
saying I want to build an architecture
that will make it easy to change this
software in the future and if we're
doing agile software development and we
want to say we don't want too much up
for an architecture what we want to do
is have a LEvolution redesign we need to
have an architecture that supports
evolutionary design we don't just get it
for free and so things like the clean
architecture are ideal for supporting
agile approaches and they're ideal for
supporting things like test-driven
development it's a bit of a refresher
coupling is the property that the module
is forced to change another does right
so I have module a and I have module B
and module a depends on some code and
module B and if I change module B
there's a risk that I also have to
change module a either because the API
surface area module B the things that
are public and exposed from it change so
I have to go away and change the code in
module a because I've changed the name
of a method or number of parameters it
takes or the behave more subtly the
behavior and module B changes
okay so the way that essentially some
died right status my side effects change
and module a has to take account
sometimes at the fact that we've changed
in some way in that area we can get into
real problems if we have in duplication
between module and module B and that is
for example I worked in a in a finance
system that calculated deltas and gammas
etc for given portfolios that you had
and that was written back in the day
when we had everything was a rich client
written in you know Windows forms or WPF
sitting on someone's machine and we had
two places for example one would think
there's more than two where some of
these values were calculated and that
meant if we decided that this
calculation was off the problem was if
you hadn't changed one this would now be
out of sync with the others and
customers had phone up and say why is my
Delta this Parvati one this page in this
value on this page we had coupling of
knowledge because you had to change that
piece of knowledge everywhere without
the system so we can say that were
loosely coupled for change to one
defense of one module doesn't impact
another module and duplicated code is a
common smell of couple so cohesion so
cohesion is the property that
essentially a module is subject to the
same forces of change right we said if
you have high cohesion we're all
changing for the same reason now imagine
that I was writing an insurance
application and in my module I
essentially allowed both the claims team
and the underwriting team depended on
the example of that module and made
changes in it so the claims guys made
changes to some of the code that dealt
with policies because it helped them do
claims and the underwriting guys may
change some stuff around policies that
helped them to change I've now got a lot
of reasons to change we may find that
the claims team and the policy team are
fighting each other over this particular
piece of software and saying well I want
to change this I want to change that we
may find they have really quite
different requirements the claims team
writing a holida code that the under
Argentine never touch
and our problem is we're getting a lot
of churn and change in this one module
and we also may find that we get it's
completely unrelated concerns creeping
into that module and the kind of when we
talk about a big ball of mud one of the
things we're talking about is they're
having low cohesion everything is kind
of tangled together there's no one place
to go to if I want to go and add if I
have a particularly use case for example
price this given policy for somebody
right then one problem can be is
everything's in one module along with
the stuff that's essentially doing my
submission process the other problem can
be the opposite sort where around which
is actually I have to go and change it
in three hundred places and so I've
worked in systems like that where
essentially there used to be a recipe
where effectively in order to change for
a given use case around how we're
pricing a portfolio there was literally
a document you download it we'd had the
fourteen places in various parts of the
code base that you had to actually go
and change stuff so what you'll want is
to keep things that change together
together and keep things that don't
change together apart right and to do
that we should look for the forces of
change this goes back as far as is a
famous paper by David Parnas called on
the criteria to be used the
decomposition of software into modules
and at a time what people did was tend
to basically build modules around the
flow of the application but Parnassus
point was that's not a good idea what
you want to do is build it around
basically change things that basically
are unstable and at the low level need
to be separate from things that
effectively high-level and stable right
so you need to keep things that change
together and so mines book has a lot of
information basically on that
okay so layering is just one of the kind
of strategies that people get into to
manage this kind of process so here is a
typical layered structure and a top
layer we have basically have the UI in
the middle layer essentially we have the
domain model in the bottom that we have
infrastructure in which such people
quite often think about is the database
do stand up and down quickly at the back
if you if you can't see or download the
slides
in first quad for the database it may
also be a call to an external service so
for example if I need to look up
postcodes it may be I'm calling external
postcode provider or payment system so
it isn't just date allow at the bottom
and in the traditional model basically a
call comes in goes to my UI layer and I
tend to call wear exercise objects in
domain or maybe I call directly down to
the database and get some get some
values out okay one of the key idea is
in layer there's a couple of few key
ideas now one key idea and layering is
essentially that it's like a cake a
layer cake and everything stands on top
of each other and so when we depend I
can only depend on things that basically
are below me so the UI can reach in and
use code in the domain or the
infrastructure but the domain can't
reach up and talk directly to UI widgets
you have to always basically depend
downwards it's for events what we call
socket dependences or effectively I
depend on you you depend on me and it's
then very hard almost impossible to
build the software okay the other thing
that layers do essentially is they
perform if you like and kept some
encapsulation so we say I'm gonna
collect together a whole other stuff
that does a similar thing right so I cut
all the things that are my domain
together
I cut all the parts of my infrastructure
to get all my UI together that has some
value because particularly if we put
some kind of abstraction which is you to
called a facade make a very
coarse-grained api to this layer I can
do two things one is I can hide the
implementation details from other layers
so in order to use this infrastructure
layer I quite often don't have to know
about the details of how I talk to the
infrastructure I may have a data access
object or a repository defined and I use
that instead I don't know anything about
in the interior details the other thing
that lets me do is change stuff to swap
one implementation of a layer for
another now people always say oh no one
ever swaps a database I mean I would
I've worked a lot of places I've swapped
databases in most of them but I've also
more commonly changed the technology
that I'm using to do data access so I
did on there too dapper - Oh what - and
hibernate they quite often shift around
right and if you have a layer you can
make that change invisible to
essentially the layer above the domain
otherwise you have to go into your
domain and start changing that as well
but the other thing you can do is
substitute fakes or mocks at this level
right
using a memory database when I'm tapped
when I'm effectively working before I
got an actual real database and finally
one other thing is that a lot of agile
developers talk about is deferring
decisions quite often when I'm working
early what I'm really trying to do is
welcome to explore my keep arches of the
main model I may not need to make a
decision at that point exactly how I
persist things the technology may not be
need to be cited I could actually defer
that decision until I know more about
the qualities of persistence that I need
I may not yet have decided at the top
layer whether I'm going to expose
everything by rest by graph QL or
whatever flavor of the week it is that
it's with this week but it don't matter
to me too much because early on they
want to drive the actual model and I can
test at different layers quite easily so
I can test at this layer for example
because I can substitute a mock out
other layers
so overall layering is a useful strategy
for organizing our code so just a quick
summary we can reason about layers so
it's wanting other things didn't we talk
too much about so I can make some from
one layer I can make some reasoning
about the layer below but behavior
without having to understand its details
implementations differ decisions about
their implementations you can minimize
dependencies between layers so if you
have a facade you can essentially reduce
the surface area of your of a given
layer to a small API that hides
implementation details and that can be
useful for testing as well right to only
test the facade not the implementation
details so I can change the
implementation details without having to
basically change my tests just showing
me that that new implementation is
correct that can be very useful for
things like data access sometimes what
we do is we divide this domain layer
into two parts service and entity by the
way layering essentially this is these
are conventional layers but you can have
as many layers as you want it's the act
of learning it's important if you look
at say for example of the ddd book one
of those evans talks about it's having
quite a significant number of layers
within your domain so you can't have
multiple layers in the main this is just
conventional but in terms what our
argument today service an entity's quite
a common distinction right and we're
really doing is we're distinguishing
between two types of business logic and
our applique
the main logic and two main logic
essentially the best way to think of
that is it's relating to the critical
things that the business needs to
actually do it's its rules that
effectively you are encoding into an
application so it's my rating engine for
your insurance policy that figures out
the fact that you smoke and you're
overweight is a problem and we're going
to charge you more money or the fact
that essentially you have points on your
license means we're gonna charge you
more for the insurance of your car
apparently being a journalist in the UK
makes you a very very high insurance
risk for cars I've no idea why an
application logic which is operated the
workflow so we're saying actually there
are a number of steps in this process
and I want to effectively separate those
out as the application logic the flow of
a particular business transaction that
operates on a number of individual
entities and remember there's quite an
important distinction we'll come back to
in a little bit so this service
therapsids application logic could and
usually coordination and control and
it's basically quite often what happens
is if we create this thing called
basically a service layer and the
service layer essentially says okay I'm
gonna provide you a facade and you can
just call me from your UI layer and each
one of those things in that service
represents a flow of some particular
business transaction
so quite commonly we actually also use
that as a transactional boundary here's
a transaction running basically within
the system a business transaction would
also may be a database transaction that
says here's an operation that I want to
complete and it has certain properties
that you can reason about we may also do
things like security right you have
access to this particular part of our
API the service layer because you are
you are authorized to run this
particular operation and there are some
variations about how we implement this
so it's only called the domain facade
and the main facade says the service
layer is just a thin layer over my
domain model which consists of objects
that hold all the behavior so in this
model we say hey our domain model should
have objects that represent things in
the field or reasoning about
a policy object a claim object a rating
object for insurance for example or in
our case Mahara where I work things like
a document a document version ideas that
are concepts in your domain all the
behavior should live there and all thing
or facade does essentially says it's a
very thin layer that essentially says
well I know in order to perform this
particular operation this entity has the
understanding of how to do that and I
will simply delegate control to that
particular entity to do it and this
gives you a very thin facade that
doesn't really have any kind of business
logic in it whatsoever so it's just a
boundary it's a layer boundary that
essentially passes operations down to
the domain the other approach is called
an operation script and the operation
script we say actually i wanted i think
only some of that logic lives within the
individual objects that form part of my
domain model but the workflow and
overall application logic should be
serviced up into the service layer
itself which i have responsibility for
running that particular logic and so 10
what tends to happen is we have a kind
of script which says do this do that
if this do this that do this if that do
that and the kind of thing can be
thought about as orchestrating the
individual domain objects so in this
kind of model you effectively get an
idea that basically you have a each one
of these services is quite often we get
implementations where you get a class
it's static it doesn't you can't create
instances of it it has methods on it and
those meta static methods on it and
those methods essentially the ones that
then create the relevant objects that
are actually needed and passed through
the workflow I'm sure some of you have
seen dotnet system design like that it
was very popular 5-10 years ago okay
ports of adapters so ports and adapters
are a layered architectural style it's
sometimes referred to as the hexagonal
architecture and that reference comes
down to basically the shape of the
diagram which was see in a second you
used to produce it now the key thing to
understand is that we have three layers
in the portion adapters architecture
we have what's the confusingly called
application-layer and that's essentially
where our policies and business rules go
so in other words are kind of the main
model lives there right and these the
web application unfortunates confused a
lot of people because people confuse
that term application with the over
running system and as a result people
get confused about what what portion
adapters are but application when coburn
uses it means essentially their domain
model in the center of your system then
there are adapters and adapters are
essentially how we get input into the
system and how we get output from the
system so an adapter of what we call a
primary adapter a one that a primary
actor so basically that's someone using
the system or another system calling you
uses could be something like effectively
an HTTP API for a system calling you for
excited be something like rich UI and
web forms and it could be a command line
interface
it can also be tests and that's
essentially your way of saying I want to
drive the interaction of your system
yeah and there's a secondary adapt which
goes to the secondary actor which is
specially for outgoing stuff so that's
basically I'm calling your database to
persist data I'm calling a message queue
to raise basically an event on your
messaging infrastructure
I'm calling SMTP to send an email as a
result your interaction between the
application and the adapters is alaric
all the ports and the ports you can
think of essentially as a service layer
they are were effectively the performer
perform effectively a facade over the
application that the adapter calls and
again you can implement them in either
basically operations an operation script
Y or effectively domain script away
where effectively you kind of say all
the behavior lives in my entities or
some of my behavior lives basically in
my in my port this is what the hexagonal
architecture looks like so this outer
ring is basically my adapters sent at me
so you can see and you can see I've got
numbers here so user side about HTTP in
GUI overhead for database adapter and
over here I've got some a different
types that's from notifications
like em keep esmtp websockets in the
center these are the circles represent
affecting my entities in the system
right this is where my this is my code
lives that basically is doing some work
and in here this line if you like with
the name as user so notifications and
database is the port that lani and the
idea is essentially that because the
reasons uses port is this concept
basically of a application exposing
ports to the on the operating system so
you can call it the idea is that the
application hit layer here he talks
about is exposing ports so it can be
called and effectively these adapters
cool right
and I can one of the ideas is that
effectively I can have different types
of adapter calling my same port right so
that's the adapter that's the
application and that's the port now I
show another diagram this in a second
but just just a reference on this screen
the important thing to understand about
the way this architecture works is that
all dependencies are in words so
adapters depend on ports which depend on
the application so that's essentially a
model so each of us on this side I think
more if you can see probably so this is
a layer diagram for hexagonal
architecture as you can see essentially
the adapter layer represents the
equivalent of our old infrastructure and
UI model in the up there right so in our
previous layer diagram absolu I they're
combined in this model they are both the
adapter learn the outer ring at the
bottom layer I've got my application
there where my policies and rules exist
in the middle there effectively I have
my port layer this is really equivalent
to my my domains service layer and this
is really covenant to my entity layer
and notice essentially I depend all the
way in so one of the questions that
comes up is well if I've got something
in the port layer and let's say for
example is my second report and it's
talking to my secondary adapter I wanted
to which basically talks to the database
right there's a problem here isn't there
because my port can't depend on my
adapter
my adaptor content map or not the other
way around so how does that work how do
i essentially say well i
want to cool some database code that
lives there and the answer if actually
is you define an interface at the layer
of your port I repository pick a name
and then you say okay in the adapter
layer because I can depend on this
interface
I will implement a concrete repository
and hibernate repository EF core
repository or whatever I want to call it
but usually a proposed you by name at
user repository okay and then at runtime
what I need to do is inject a concrete
representation of that particular type
into the system so that effectively
that's where dependency injection comes
from this notion that I declare
dependency on a I user repository and at
runtime something would call the
composition roots in other words when
you come into the application says when
I in order to build this application I
need to effectively inject a concrete
representation into that particular
piece of code so that effectively it
will run this is what IOC containers
were built for they have been much
abused and badly used over the years but
IOC contains a dependency injection were
built to basically allow you to continue
to layer in one direction but have this
code effectively be implemented in a
different layer that makes sense that's
me wonder what di is about that's what
di is about okay on domains let's talk a
little bit I'm gonna stand over here for
a little bit cuz I think it's um okay so
this is ivory Jakub sins book anyone
read it apart from me a couple of people
wow yeah so it's mainly famous for use
cases this is what a use case looks like
so the idea essentially is I have some
kind of actors and effectively they are
it's a map of basically the behaviors
that we want to model in or not model in
our system so here essentially is a use
case model around effectively ordering
some food and you can see there are
given interactions that we may or may
not want to base represent in our system
by code I'm not teaching use cases to
just get an ID and no need to get the
idea of it
so one of the things that ya Kirsten
came up with this idea called boundary
controller entity and boundary
controller entity was a way of modeling
use cases if you had them so a boundary
object this is the UML notation for a
boundary object this stuff has its own
you amount notations okay so this is a
boundary object and the boundary object
is anything that interfaces with the
actors of the system actors in the use
case were being something external so
basically a user wanted to type
something in very user interface a
database where you're persisting data to
another system that you're talking to to
look up information or exchange it right
we can see a pattern here surely
okay so boundary object basically
effectively is that and here you can see
a diagram effectively of a recycling
machine where effectively you've got a
customer panel or a seat printer they
are all boundary objects in the system
so an entity object in this model it's
something that has States and the
operations that essentially depend upon
that state so we can slice a pod in
Maine a little bit is we can say okay
here are some things something like
address right and here are all the
operations that depend upon address and
that's one way of figuring out what
lives in an entity and what lives in a
controller or interactor okay and a
controller sits between a boundary and
an entity boundary is not allowed to
talk directly to entities and the
controller says I will mediate the
conversation between these two now a use
case is if description of the way the
system is used it specifies the input to
be provided by the user the output to be
returned by the user and the processing
steps that are involved especially the
workflow and some controllers or
interactors essentially are way you
implement a use case and quite often
you're advised to name that controller
after that use case so you say this is
my rate policy use case so it's the
entry point where you can track that use
case this has a significant advantage it
means when I want to go and look at the
of my system understand how we do rating
of a policy where is the code behind
this thing that we do I simply go and
look for the use case describing rating
policy which is a controller in the
system and effectively I can find the
code and the code will drive certain
entities which effectively have the
state and the behavior that depends upon
that state inside them so provides the
application logic so for example it will
load entities from the database for
example and persist them at the end rays
events etc lose some of that work but
it'll also do things like say oh well
you know I'm gonna decide whether you're
a gold customer I need to take this
particular route etcetera so the use
case lives in the controller interactor
so we're not with a model this would
like this there's the actor on the
outside the individual and essentially
he's talking via a banner EUI for
example or an api and he's then talking
to some control objects which
effectively then orchestrate the
behavior of the entity objects so you
can see that these structures again
related right here as our adapter port
an application and we can see that our
boundary is really Coburn's adapter and
our port is really
Yakob syns controller and our
application layer for coburn is where
our entities live and Coburn's quite
explicit he says that a port is the
use-case boundary right use potations
for compromise when they're only
technology consent so what we do is we
say effectively I'd want to take my use
cases out of where technology lives and
but that really he means the code-behind
for your razor page or the oil or web
forms page even worse the the event
handlers on your your GUI right take the
code out of there because in order to
test that for example I now have to
write a test which spins out that
particular piece of infrastructure and
my test dependent on the infrastructure
all those people that write their tests
and they spin up their MVC controller
one of the problems is if I wanted to
change from an MVC control to something
else my tests have got a dependency on
the controller that's no good to me
I want to depend on the use case that's
what I want to drive the tests of and so
that's that controller layer for the
boundaries controllers entities that
portal effects hang on architects
is where we actually write our tests
don't get confused by the way between
MVC style controller and the boundaries
controllers and entities in a child
controller which is also a port some
people use the firt the phrase
boundaries interactors and entities to
try and make sure that you don't get
this confused about what which
controller is the controller is a
stereotype it's in other words it's a
type of thing with a certain behavior
it's not a specific MVC controller so
hit looking are hexagonal architecture
again you can see we've got boundary
objects entity objects and control
objects right the test focus on the
behavior at the use-case boundaries so
here basically we're saying we unit
testing at the port it's the user case
boundaries as we write our tests they're
writing against the entities it's too
granular to write them against the
adapters you now have test the dependent
technology concerns write your tests
against the port I do a much bigger talk
called TD whether it will go wrong when
we talk about this issue so if you're
interested in diving in depth to that
particular question that that talk we'll
talk about it for you find it online we
don't tend to test the adapters we have
some integration tests to test a hook up
of a particular port but you can then
also use some system tests at the
outside to effectively make sure
everything works together right so
really your emphasis is pretty much on
doing most things by unit testing at the
port boundary with a few tests around
the outside to give you confidence okay
the use case controller over to this
side mister you all post it okay so this
is essentially by the way vertical slice
architecture so this is I mean boundary
control and entity is vertical slice as
well really okay
so the use case controller was pattern
was created by in 2001 or catalog could
be a better way of saying it they didn't
create it there since she just actually
cattle but this pattern existent people
were using it where Susan Pinter and
what the question was is how do you
design systems that basically have use
cases and they wanted to preserve the
idea of the use case not to put a
traceback
behaviour to a given use case and make
it call over from UI and open to
extension as a point in here which is a
bit different for everybody else they're
saying they want to be open to extension
what they mean by that is effectively I
want for to compose things so I've got
one use case or
to actually be able to do is have same
macro use case call that other one so
sometimes I'm basically doing a bulk
operation here's a typical use case for
an order processing system and that's
typically what you used to end up back
in they don't and you know I'm not ask
you to understand that diagram by the
way called basically a activity diagram
we're going to worry about what these
are too much but this behavior here this
flow is essentially what we mean when we
talk about basically application logic
that a flow of actually going through
and saying okay effectively you know do
we have more this to do what information
do we need that kind of thing cetera
what are the states which what the
states we move through basically in the
in this item so that looks a bit like
that
I say use classic use case realization
you can see there's a place order we've
got an interface where the user types in
their order managers are really bad
where don't let me use that but here's
the place order use case and it involves
the order of product entities over here
updating accounts as well so we have an
account manager a use case basically an
account entity and the ladira is place
orders going to basically have some kind
of interaction with the update account
use use case so it needs to call it or
well within some way and so in this kind
of model now they've made a bit of a
mistake which was essentially to use
view and model to try and make it
sympathetic to the idea of MVC forget
that's a bad idea but the model there is
essentially your entity and your view
there is your is essentially your
boundary object because they view is the
how I talk to the outside world and the
model is my as my entities but the use
case controller as you can see
essentially talks about essentially an
idea of starting and finishing it's a
flow it's moving through various states
and this idea over here extensions
inclusions is the bed products the same
thing they're effectively plugging in
and other virtual use cases extensions
just have some kind of some pretty
conditioning okay the details are not
just our import we're just trying to
show you that this is a kind of old idea
that can be synthesized
okay and the model is identify use cases
for each use case create use case
controller and then create the entity in
boundary classes you need to implement
so you can drive TDD against the US
Coast controller and then basically
provide the implementation to that as
you go along
and then it creates tension looks
related use cases I think they're
talking about is saying you know really
what you want to do is package your use
cases in a separate layer so one of the
things that you know I'd pushback about
is people saying they were doing
vertical slice architecture we're not
doing layers they are doing layers there
are layers throughout the idea of
vertical slice okay and it gets like
possession the British words and
policies an easier place for the system
of course we talked about this before
actually we've got all the rules and
policies basically localized but we can
easily replace some of the things that
the boundaries user interfaces etc I can
swap wine easier interface for another I
could build a REST API over what was
once just by CA Web API and flexible
configuration using plugin or extension
model etc okay I won't interesting thing
to note is that they say a one way you
can implement this is using the command
a command process a pattern so this idea
of saying I take a command and I
basically fire off to some kind of
handler and along the way I may complete
a number of orthogonal steps in some
kind of chain of responsibility anyone
want to Jimmy talk yes they would have
seen doing that in vertical slice and
that's basically in this idea of use
case controller okay clean architecture
this is what the clean architecture
looks like which is essentially is a
synthesis of all these ideas so in the
center we have our entities and our yeah
Kherson we're talking about earlier
surrounding is effectively our use case
layer essentially which is where our
controllers are living since you are
ports here we talked about controllers
and gateways and presenters were talking
about how we work with a given framework
right so this is where effectively we
implement our espied on an MVC
controller to plug into the outer layer
the outer layer essentially is
everything beyond this database is
frameworks
external interfaces so what mines done
effectively you just make these layers
and to name them a bit differently but
make them clearer about what the
combination of these events all is okay
so sorry that slide is a little bit hard
to read isn't it
you see what happens if I change
the theme was let me try again hmm
better ish isn't it okay right so what
happens is by some mechanism stuff comes
into our application we have basically a
boundary object which is essentially how
we relate to whatever framework or
mechanism is delivering inputs into us
we construct basically a request model
from that input we call an interactive
some other something some kind of layer
does it the use case all right and that
basically orchestrates an operation on a
number of entities it matter this is
entity gateway so you might as a talk
basically potentially to something to
load those entities up okay so typically
for us what you might see with this ends
they've got some kind of API framework
layers for an MVC or a web api and
effectively online writing my controller
and essentially what I get into the
controller is it takes the post
variables and turns men to a request
model I passed it down to my interactor
and then I get back a response model now
where I have MVC inside some tonight as
when an NBC it's really all at this
layer right so my web controller
effectively is dealing with that down
here so don't make the mistake of
leaving that other layer and then
essentially if I have basically a
database down here that's potentially
where I get my entities from by entity
framework core or the like okay wow that
was an interesting change of styles and
okay I'm not expecting that all right
let's show you some code and then we'll
come back and hope that we can get that
design transition to something that will
not kill the rest of my slides okay
right can we switch over to I switch
screen and I'm not appearing on here
so I've just switched off the PowerPoint
presentation like a mirror screens
woman's in my screens okay mirror the
screens guys and then you'll be able to
see what I can see shimmering in the
manual of the way it goes black okay all
right let's show you this okay I'm gonna
increase the size a bit can you read
that in the back ish bit bigger good
little bit bigger
okay so here's why it's might use a demo
application I'm just going to run
through what the API does for a second
for you so I built this fantastically
complicated demo application that
essentially says you can post to me some
greetings and then you can ask to get
them back right and the reason it's very
simple is because that means we're not
worried about what the domain actually
is in the context of this operation so
here I'm going to basically say I'm
gonna go away and get guys that not
showing me my plugin hello what's going
wrong with you
okay I'm gonna is using a plug-in called
dynamic rest so I made a call to the web
server and the web server said
effectively I haven't got anything at
the time being and then I can post in a
greeting request I got a response back
that tells me essentially here's the
idea of what you just gave me I can post
in another one right and I can think
I've got a third one down here and I'm
gonna go back and get them all I get the
whole list right and I can ask for an
individual one by ID but I'm not going
to show you that it's not relevant to
the conversation okay now this is
typically how a lot of people might
naively have created their initial
controller I'm doing everything
essentially in the controller
there's no layering at all whatsoever
basically available to you here so you
can see here in the get I'm just saying
okay well great way into the framework
context and go away and run
basically a query of putting into an
array and it's right through the results
and display that out effectively on a
result so I've got some MVC logic going
on but I've got no real layering you can
see here for example and a post ignore
the loads of console stuff explain it
later but you can see here essentially I
am creating a context I'm adding
something I do have a repository just to
hide away some of the entity framework
or craft but yeah the perceptions are
adding something to the repo okay
probably many of you have seen
applications and look a lot like that
where everything is just straight in the
controller and the problem now is that I
can't get that code to test it
independent the controller or to change
it or to use it from somewhere else if
effectively they're actual and if some
of that logic was useable somewhere else
that'd be useful and you can see here
I'm repeating similar logic you'll see
that effectively in a lot of places I
pull back this result object right or I
pull back a result object this is doing
exactly the same things it's a repeated
code so what I might decide to do is say
well I went to that talking in talked
about layers so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to pull in did
you do that you never did that normally
okay right okay I'm gonna basically
create my layer and what I'm gonna do is
say here is my layer call greeting
facade and I'm gonna move stuff down
there so now I've got a LAN and now I
could be able to do is for example I got
facade get async and I've got facade
basically greet okay it's cleaner I've
got all these places where I'm doing get
async and it's all using the same code
so I've remove some duplication also
where I've got that had that horrible
piece of console stuff I've now got a
thing called re greet that's fine it's
taking as much cleaner and easier to
read and I've got the nice thing for add
okay and I can go and I'd never get over
the way that's done and you will find
essentially I've just moved all the code
down here now the thing is this is much
more testable right I could now write my
tests against this facade layer and I've
removed in dependency I have on the MVC
framework so if I tried to change
frameworks and that sounds crazy but
once the runtime people believe that web
forms is going to be here forever
imagine that I still deal with code
written in web form was because the
people that wrote it believed it would
be here forever
and I can now test this layer quite
independently now I'm a discerning gonna
go a step further I may decide that
essentially I've got a lot of stuff in
that one facade a maybe even though my
case I'm just doing a simple crud if my
add operation and my delete operation
had a lot of additional business logic
around what it was actually doing there
lot of it be not a complexity in one
single class and really add and delete
are quite separate use cases because you
know in a genuine application am I have
a lot of additional flow in them so what
I might do is decide to basically take
hold of the single responsibility
principle and break all this up if I can
yep so let's get rid of that okay so now
what you should see is that effectively
in my greetings controller I have an add
greeting service and a regreat service
and a greetings by ID service and all
they've done is I've taken the
individual items there and said okay -
put that for making its own individual
class so now effectively I've got
something that looks like it's handling
individual use cases okay now I could
look at that and say you know what
that's really surely just the command
model okay
the reason has these from discuses i'm
shifting between repose and omni sharp
needs to get a sharp restart did you
just go and just told you to do that
because I need to reinitialize basically
it's intellisense okay so as you can
turn this into commands and queries so
I've got an a greeting command here for
example right which you execute async so
the a greeting can one is very similar
to that service but I'm now explicitly
calling it a command it's something I
want to do I mean most before
effectively under user case controller
the authors were saying commands and
command processes are a good way to
implement this okay and commands and
natural transactional boundaries so my
use case is now a command that I'm
operating on the system
and I can also encapsulate up because I
may feel CQRS see I can essentially say
hey look at my query is also something I
can encapsulate at this level okay
that's just doing the same thing and now
I may say well hang on a minute
now I'm talking directly to concrete
commands but wouldn't it be nice to have
some kind of model where effectively
between me and the final execution I can
assert a hold of orthogonal concerns
like logging in the command processor
model okay so essentially that's where
we move over to this where we just get
this right
I'm gonna say okay I'm gonna bring in
basically brighter and darker which the
libraries love as I work on but other
libraries are available immediately
there's a lot of this for you as well
for example and I'm gonna say okay right
so this command person and query
processor here
I just essentially come on processor is
brighter and Corey presser is darker and
what I say here is I'm going to
basically separate the parameters from
the execution so the greetings so for
example the grit the add greeting
request command now doesn't have a body
it just says essentially instead here
effectively is my parameters and what
happens at run time is that we navigate
to an actual handler so the handler
lives in here you can see we basically
called the ports directory so we're
basically trying to be explicit about
our architecture and surface that idear
up and they're effectively is my ad
greeting command and you can see on the
a guillotine command as well as
essentially doing the actual work we've
been doing all along of adding something
to the repository we have these
attributes and that's what we use in
brighter to indicate an orthogonal
operations it's Russian doll model we
just insert more handlers into the chain
what we're saying here is you want to
use some policies from Polly to control
our retry or circuit breaker a approach
we want to do some logging so use policy
comes out of the box so this thing for
example we're saying I try and talk to
database and add your command oh and by
the way if you fail to talk to the
database for some reason maybe there's a
deadlock maybe there's a temporary
partition on the network will retry the
operation for you according to the
policy if the operation fails a lot then
will break the circuit for you so that
you don't keep polluting essentially the
logs with basically failed operations
and will log everything for you will
show you essentially entry and exit
basically from that particular method so
we're moving into that long chain we've
eventually made up made it possible for
ourselves to put those orthogonal
concerns into the chain before we reach
our target Handler and I'll testify I
don't got any tests but I tested we were
gonna write them this is what we'd
actually target right we would target
this handler we would say I want to test
this handler does what it's supposed to
and that means I can vary my
implementation details a lot and I don't
have to rewrite my tests this is really
over time we've come to believe the
optimal place to actually do our testing
is that this use case boundary which is
basically our handler so you think of
your handlers a use case boundary okay
let's take off mirroring go back to some
slides I keep changing the color of my
slide so I have no idea what will happen
now in terms of the format but we'll
live we'll work with it okay so let's
create interesting lines across my
screen isn't it let's just live with it
the fact that it's changed stuff for us
this is the service of Saud and
essentially what we're saying is this is
kind of the very simplest level where
effectively we have some kind of class
and it has methods on it which represent
the individual use cases that we're
talking about okay I'm too far away to
change the page oops
something's crashed probably Kindle quit
unexpectedly you don't really care about
that D okay so the interface segregation
principle is a first step we didn't
really show that but essentially I might
say well effectively what I want to do
is break up my that's gone hideously
wrong in that format let me just change
it if I can change back to the original
design and then we may find that our
lives are a little bit less painful
let's hope with readability and layout
okay so essentially we've got this idea
of saying well I could effectively
decide that my service consists of a
range of interfaces so I could say
actually it consists of an update my
theme this applet my think that way each
one of those is an individual use case
right and again it relates to a single
responsibility so a beat we're creating
cohesion by saying each use case not all
the use cases in one class well the
other thing is you're concerned about is
if you have one big fat class that
essentially implements all of your use
cases your problem is it has a lot of
dependencies and so things that you
don't depend on in your use case if they
change you effectively have to retest
your whole class because something else
changed not related to you so better
cohesion you want to break up into
individual use cases then we get to the
model we were talking about saying okay
so you guys wants multi principle so
effectively I'm going to just implement
each one of those interfaces is its own
class so in fact we have a use case is
now an individual class not basically a
service force our class right and then
we get basically into the command pan
this is the comeup app that has never
seen it essentially what we have is this
abstract notion of a command that you
can execute and the execution on the
command is what exercises your entities
in your domain model how at the client
level
you essentially say well right I'm
effectively going to implement a deal
with a concrete instance of that okay
and so what happens is the client calls
the command and says create a new one
and effectively it says the quite often
it's the whole bit about destroy and
invoke and we'll just skip the second
cuz it's not relevant then the effect
you want to execute affect you that
command right so can ones very simple
I've got to execute method on it and
effectively what I say is do my stuff
the parameters going is that in the
constructor and the execution is there
and your command is effectively where
you create a use case I don't know why I
ended up with this projector model let's
try flipping can you see that better we
just do that maybe you know
there we go right so this model
effectively is showing you the earlier
diagram basically with commands where we
had interacted before whoops we're
saying basically just use a command okay
and the effectively you can see our
delivery mechanism exif is our NBC MVC
our boundary would go where are
effectively our embassy controller when
we create a request model which
essentially the form post variables that
are basically coming in to a parameter
to a web controller we then turn them
essentially into properties on a command
we which we then effectively execute to
basically bring out our entities from
the database fire and did you framework
core and then deal with them and we get
a response back okay assemblers so this
is effectively you made have to deal
with data transfer objects between the
layers and assemblers are worth doing
that autumn a per is an example
essentially of an assembler which is
aware of effectively quoting data
transfer objects from domain objects
don't write the code by hand right okay
this can lead you towards c'mon query
separation which is not the purpose of
this talk but you can begin to
understand how you're building up a
command model and a query model which
basically from your UI so you have some
kind of task based interface which is
relating commands which is changing the
state and a query model which is then
interpreting that States and that
command query separation is a fairly
easy step once you begin to work in this
way okay so one of your commands is
essentially a use case and a use case
controller pan a vertical slice moving
through those layers and most of that
Kanwar dispatcher so can well dispatcher
effectively which this idea essentially
that we said well what I want to do is
separate the execution of the command
from its parameters so essentially what
I would say is essentially I'll take a
whole load of commands and I'll register
them and I registered when it eventually
when that when I basically pass a
command it will go and look up the
relevant Handler and call this execute
method okay so here you basically get a
sequence diagram showing you essentially
a register handle with dispatcher and
when effectively I actually wanted to
set the sent to invoke a command what I
do is go away and look up the actual
handler and then effectively invoked the
handler passing in the parameters
all right so you know that okay that's
to watch the end and we're doing we got
about four or five minutes left okay I
will just quickly show you that bit that
bit of code again just to final state
and then we can do have it ponder and if
you have a question let's do let's
mirror this line oh you can see that
okay okay you can see my code right so
just to kind of look at that final state
of the object again you can kind of see
you've got a controller the controller's
creating a command it's basically using
a dispatcher to send that command
basically effectively to a handler and
orthogonal e we're basically running a
number of steps to basically handle
orthogonal concerns for example in our
case retry logic circuit breakers and
logging by the way don't do transactions
in your orthogonal steps it's painful we
tried that and what happens is is
essentially your transaction boundary
one it may span other orthogonal steps
so it's held open for a long period of
time and two when you're actually inside
your handler really want to now the
transaction to be a short or wind as
possible if it turns out some you know
junior programmer comes along like so
call to an external service your
transaction is now spanning that
external service call at the same time
or even more commonly writing writing to
and from disk so void using basically
putting transactions into those
orthogonal steps it hurts in the end
okay so this is basically post and you
can see we're simply using a query for
gate ID and you can see then over then
just to remind you then what happens is
you end up looking like this a greeting
come on handle or other and that
essentially is where you write your use
case right think of this is your use
case your command is your use case
boundary and you write it here and in
here you can do with entities you can
also actually in this model you can vary
it you can have a secure what we call a
transaction script so you could just
have no entities at all
talk to the database if you wanted to in
some environments that's actually just
as appropriate not to have you have no
real policies or rules you're just doing
crud then effectively sometimes what you
do is just put that crud straight in
here into the handler and you have no
underlying entity layer okay any
questions now stand you'll
okay so the question is if I'm in my
interface layer how do I understand
what's happened in my domain object so
the answer is events right so what you
had to do is raise events what you don't
do this it usually has raised the event
directly for the domain object what you
actually do is quit in a port layer and
basically in this handler you're
essentially criminal jet ask if it has
any events and then you would
essentially be able to publish them and
you publish them generally or quaff into
an interface or you can publish them to
some other models so we have here I
think in this one let me do this one
with the workers so this version which I
didn't show you the time but I'll show
you now in this version what we're going
to do is say on the a greeting command
handler I'm going to post an event and
if you can see that and he tries
scrolling the screen up a bit I'm gonna
post effectively a something out here so
I'm saying I'm going to raise an event
in response to what happened internally
here now when we're using posting brides
what we mean is I'm going to put that
over a message key because you think
something out of process is going to
handle that we also have essentially
published which does it in process and
you seem to discover another hand and to
put that up effectively if I want to go
all the way to the UI right not another
handler then essentially what I'm really
doing quite often is just querying the
results basically through the UI layer
separately so I do a separate query that
says what are the results of that
operation once it's completed we would
tend to know when there when the
operation is finished either you've
basically got an async publish or send
in which case effectively use right on
your completion this actually we're
actually you want to go and then query
that result for it
or we won't return we'll block until
basically process the actual information
and then you get to go and query it
so what remember publishing an event and
posting one yeah yeah yeah this one
basically puts it at a process to a
separate process worker just actually
completely out of the application so
it's using idea basic called task keys
so toski basically says I've got some
work I don't want to do handle in
process I want to offload that to some
other system to do I'm say for example
if I was actually going to mail that to
you fetch of i-70 Pearson on running
operation and what I do is raise it so
over here you're fine we've got a read
command handler which is handling that
work and you'll find down here this is a
separate basically application that's
running the defects because we call
dispatcher that listens effectively
message on a queue and then wait as it
receives them or handle them
this one is listening on this particular
to this particular topic notification
and rabbitmq and creates a particular
queue for that and essentially when it
receives those it will effectively
automatically send them to your handler
for you but you can you can play with
the code is on github I'm gonna have a
look a brighter weeks we've got quite
extensive documentation to explain how
it all works
any other questions
all right then I think we're done
[Applause]